(Music)
Poppy Scoville-Parnell:
Nineteen years ago,
Chuck Berman was murdered.
Poppy Scoville-Parnell:
The focus was quickly turned to
Warren Cave.
And that's where I come in.
Poppy Scoville-Parnell:
I helped seal Warren's fate with
series of articles.
Poppy Scoville-Parnell:
Is there an innocent man in
prison, and did I lead that charge?
I'd like you to reconsider.
(Music)
Lauren Neustadter:
Octavia's character Poppy, has a
podcast called, Reconsider.
Lauren Neustadter:
And it's very fitting for this
case because we're reconsidering,
Warren Cave's guilt or
innocence.
And we're re-examiining what
actually happened in the crime.
Aaron Paul:
She decides to start a podcast,
and that old skeletons have been dug up.
What did you find?
Your father was unaccounted for,
the time we took Bremans
murder.
Lizzy Caplan:
It rides the wave of the true
crime podcasts craze, that we all enjoy.
Lizzy Caplan:
it's exploring what happens to
the real people involved in
Lizzy Caplan:
these stories that we get a kick
out of discussing around the water cooler.
Octavia Spencer:
Poppy chose a podcast as a
medium, because it is a path of least resistance.
And you can reach the masses.
Lanie, this podcast about your
family, has people talking.
Brett Cullen:
The podcast is the thing that
ties us to her and also her emotional
Brett Cullen:
thinking of where her characters
at and what she believes, and how she expresses the doubts,
Brett Cullen:
and a, convictions she has.
Aaron Paul:
That's what I think is so great
about the show and podcasts like this show and true crime
dramas, is that it just keeps
you on your toes.
Kristen Campo:
We're our own detectives.
We wanna be the ones solving the
crime.
Lizzy Caplan:
It's getting to explore our
greatest fears as human beings,
Lizzy Caplan:
in a way that feels
completely safe.
I'm Poppy Parnell, thank you for
listening.
(Music)